so for those who wanted Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man to return or simply there to
be a Spider-Man in the Venom Spider-Man
universe that Sony is now building right
now looks like we are getting our wish
according to recent reports Sony has
plans for Andrew Garfield in fact they
had some pretty big plans for Andrew
Garfield lined up for the Madam Webb
movie however also according to other
reports he's not just going to be
limited to Sony to the Sony Spider-Man
universe side of things and that he
could actually be appearing in the MCU
in fact one report suggests that he is
going to be around even after Avengers
Secret Wars in the MCU which a lot of
people would just really freak out about
now we know that Tom Holland Spider-Man
is going to remain in the MCU after
Avengers Secret Wars along with some
other main MCU characters as well so it
makes total sense plus not to mention we
have heard that not only is Toby Maguire
Spider-Man going to be returning for
Avengers Secret Wars but he is actually
going to be one of the main characters
of the story of Avengers Secret Wars but
it does seem like Sony and Marvel are
indeed going to eventually cross over
most likely in Avengers Secret Wars and
the good news is it does seem like they
do at least have a outline of a plan on
Sony's side and it really does seem like
they are building up to something pretty
big including a big Crossover with the
MCU so a lot of great news to go over
today for Spider-Man fans now before we
dive into the good news I unfortunately
have to start this video off with some
bad news but the bad news is kind of
good at the same time in my opinion the
bad news is we could have had Andrew
Garfield appear in a movie this year in
2024 so we're going to miss out on that
however the good news that comes with
this is the movie was Madam web a movie
that many people believe is not going to
be very good so rather than having
Andrew Garfield appear in a movie that
is probably going to be a lot like the
other Sony spiderverse movies that we've
seen they're saving him for hopefully
something better so like I said bad and
good give and take win and lose I'd
rather see him appear in a really epic
way like in venom 3 than to see him play
kind of a small part in another movie
that might not be so good this news is
coming from The Insider Jeff Snider on
the hot mic podcast where he stated Sony
wanted Andrew Garfield to be the
Spider-Man of Madam web then changed
plans to Tom Holland then realized they
did the timeline wrong so they reshot
and removed everything referencing
Spider-Man and a particular year which
is really really interesting on a few
different levels one and not to talk too
badly about Sony but they wanted to do
this but then realized that they got it
wrong I'm sorry it seems like a very
Sony Spider-Man thing to do at this
point with all of the films that we've
had so far it just seems like they kind
of don't really have or at least before
didn't really have a well flushed out
plan something else that is pretty
interesting is that they wanted Tom
Holland the reason that's kind of
interesting and a little bit confusing
is because Marvel Studios for the first
Venom film did not want Tom Holland to
appear in that film Sony did in that
disagreement Marvel Studios won since
Tom Holland was the Spider-Man of the
MCU Marvel said they didn't want him to
appear in venom because they didn't want
the audience to confuse the universes
they didn't want people to think that
Tom Holland Spider-Man was in the Venom
Universe now since then we know that a
lot has happened with Marvel Studios and
Sony and it does seem like they are
playing really really nicely with each
other right now and we know that
contracts can be renewed and we know
that in fact they have a new contract in
fact we know that Tom Holland himself
has recently signed a new contract as
well so it's definitely possible but I
still find it interesting that Sony
would want Tom Holland and not Andrew
Garfield when it seems like the plan is
to have Andrew Garfield appear in the
Sony Spider-Man universe more often than
Tom Holland however moving forward we do
know that Sony and Marvel Studios have
plans to cross over in fact this is
basically already happened in the post
credit scene of Venom Let There Be
Carnage and the post-credit scene of
Spider-Man no way home a lot of of
people including myself at first just
thought that well both of these credit
scenes were made specifically to get a
symbiote in the MCU But as time went on
we realized and insiders have reported
that there's more to this than meets the
eye yes it did put the Venom symbiote in
the MCU but Marvel Studios could have
done that on their own without having
the universes cross over because now the
origin for Venom in the MCU is that he
came from a different universe but that
conveniently fits into the story that
the MCU is good going through right now
the Multiverse Saga but also here's the
thing not only does Sony own the rights
to Spider-Man but also Venom so Sony
wants and will legally get a piece of
the action which is really why they
teamed up with the MCU in the first
place Kevin fige basically went to Amy
Pascal and said yeah we're going to do
it better let us do it and that is
indeed what happened the same thing is
basically going to happen with Venom and
this is already been confirmed with
these post-credit scenes but let's not
forget about the morbius post-credit
scene and the reference to Spider-Man
clearly Sony has their own plan of
bringing their own Spider-Man to their
Spider-Man universe which is now
believed to be Andrew Garfield Madam
Webb is supposed to be a Multiverse
movie at least the start of the
Multiverse in the Sony Spider-Man
universe in the comics Madame Webb has
the ability to travel throughout the
Multiverse so it's widely believed that
they are setting that up with Madame
Webb so them wanting Tom Holland in the
movie doesn't mean that they don't want
Andrew Garfield to appear in other
movies Tom Holland could simply be the
Peter Parker Spider-Man that we know
from the MCU so this would have been
really kind of the second or third step
in the universes crossing over and there
have been really at this point many
steps to make that happen Spider-Man now
way home showed us you know all of the
villains from the other Spider-Man
universes owned by Sony plus the other
Spider-Man were there as well then the
post credits for morbius Venom 2 and
Spider-Man no way home clearly there's a
plan here and like I mentioned in the
beginning the plan goes beyond the
Multiverse Saga which is incredibly
interesting and we'll talk about that in
just a bit but first big thank you to
Avatar braving the elements for
sponsoring this video I know many of you
love the breakdowns that we do Easter
egg videos reactions and reviews on this
channel which is why I think you will
love Avatar braving the elements the
official Companion podcast for avatar
The Last Airbender now I personally love
companion podcasts that go with whatever
I'm watching at the time because I feel
like you just get so much more
information that you wouldn't get from
anywhere else which is why I am so
excited for Avatar braving the elements
each week hosts Janet vanney the voice
of Kora and Dante Bosco the voice of
Zuko rewatch every episode of The Last
Airbender they're joined by special
guests like the casts super fans and
even the creators of the show Michael D
Martino and Brian kitko for a deep dive
and a behindthescenes look into the
Avatar verse that you can't get anywhere
else so listen to Avatar braving the
elements wherever you get your podcast
Insider my time to shine hello did a ask
ask me anything on Twitter back in
October of 2023 so a few months ago and
he was asked any plans for Garfield
Spidey post reboot in which she replied
yes then was asked a followup to the
Garfield question is Andrew himself on
board or is it still a work in progress
sort of deal in which she replied with
he is on board so Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man seems to be here for the long
term but some people have asked well how
exactly is this going to work well with
the reboot remember it's a soft reboot I
believe everyone is going to be very
well aware of the Multiverse and I think
Multiverse travel might even be pretty
possible and maybe even common post
reboot which would make for quite an
interesting Marvel Cinematic Universe
but more importantly for Sony that opens
up a lot for them like for Spider-Man
the one being used in the MCU Tom
Hollands being able to go into their
Universe without it really being that
big of a deal and remember they said set
this up with the post credit for Venom
Let There Be Carnage we can assume that
the events of Spider-Man no way home are
what brought Venom to the MCU and then
pushed him back to his universe but
whatever the events may be even if those
aren't what actually made it happen it's
very clear that that event that brought
Venom to the MCU and then back happened
in both the Sony spiderverse and the MCU
this is what is setting up the big
crossover plus not to mention it is
widely believed that Sony is planning
for some type of spider gon storyline
where a bunch of different Spider-Man
variants come together in a liveaction
movie and again if you look back based
on everything we've talked about today
we can see how they are indeed setting
something like that up now as far as why
they didn't use Tom Holland because the
story year was off well it's pretty much
been proven at this point that Madam web
is going to take place in the year 2003
based off of what we have seen from the
trailer in the trailer we can see a
billboard that is a Calvin Klein display
that was shown in real life in New York
City in 20 03 we also see a man reading
a newspaper that's an article about the
legend Gary Carter being inducted into
the Hall of Fame this happened in real
life in 2003 and one of the biggest ones
is that a Set photo from Madame Webb
shows a banner for Beyonce's 2003 debut
album Dangerously in Love so Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man or Tom Holland
Spider-Man would not be Spider-Man here
The Amazing Spider-Man came out in 2012
then Tom Holland Spider-Man was way
after with Civil War in 2016 so if any
Spider-Man were to show up it would
definitely be Toby Maguire Spider-Man
since the timeline would line up then
Toby Maguire's first Spider-Man film
released in 2002 and it does seem like
with Ezekiel Sims and Madam Webb they
are indeed going to tie in a bunch of
different timelines and a bunch of
different Spider-Man so I would not be
surprised if Toby Maguire Spider-Man has
a cameo in this movie especially since
we learned that they wanted Andrew
Garfield and then they wanted Tom
Holland now I know they wanted Tom
Holland just so they could get him in
the film ad advertise it and get people
to go watch the movie based off of Tom
Holland being in the film which honestly
yeah it would have worked people who
weren't interested in Madam web would
probably go watch it just to watch Tom
Holland Spider-Man but unfortunately
things didn't work out so if they had to
scrap Tom Holland Spider-Man and Andrew
Garfield's because the timeline didn't
work out then that means they might
revert back to Toby Maguire Spider-Man
because the timeline does match up but
overall it looks like we are getting
more of Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Toby
Maguire Spider-Man and of course Tom h
Spider-Man in both the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the Sony spiderverse it
looks like all three of these Spider-Man
are going to be jumping back and forth
which is really really exciting news but
let's just hope that they do it right
they do it in a really great way that
really excites fans and does the
characters Justice fingers crossed on
that one but hey let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below what do you think of this news and
if you have any theories be sure to let
us know don't forget to like the video
and subscribe stay up to date on the MCU
and Sony spiderverse and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in a giveaway for
chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof